welcome to the global roundtable this
series focuses on the future of economic
competition I'm Parag Khanna joined by a
distinguished panel including dambisa
moyo Daniel Altman and uncared heartless
today we're going to be talking about
the political power of youth and social
media obviously we're focusing very much
on the Middle East where there's been
tremendous amount of upheaval largely
driven by youth by technology the Al
Jazeera effect whatever the case may be
across the entire Arab world but very
different in each case we're sitting and
watching bystanders like everyone else
but what can you say what can we say
about where this is going to go I think
it's been fascinating to watch both
what's happened there and then the sum
of the debate about technology that
we've had in the West relating to it
there's been a lot of kind of vitriolic
commentary saying this these revolutions
are entirely caused by Facebook and
Twitter on the one hand and people who
say they've played no role I think a
kind of Middle truth is emerging where
the inability of people to keep out
governments to keep out information you
can't just shut off the TV you can shut
off the internet but then Google invents
a system that you can use voice mail to
tweet the inability of governments to
totally shut themselves out is likely to
become a more and more potent this
technology though going to lead to
better policy better economic policy to
democracy technology can be
democratizing by itself and I don't
think we should just talk about the
teenage and twenty year old tweeters we
should talk about the 30 year old and 40
year old tweeters too because they're
the ones that lack the economic
opportunities that they thought they
deserved based on their skills and
education in these regimes if the new
regimes are much more meritocratic it
will be an effect of the fact that these
30 and 40 year-old tweeters were the
ones who put them in power I would argue
that a lot of these countries are going
to be better off despite the uncertainty
that we're facing today that even as
they fumble and stumble through economic
reforms the amount of attention that's
going to be on them because of media
because of Technology because youth can
go out in the streets is going to be
incredibly intense they're not going to
have this long window of opportunity to
talk and say the nice nice things about
how they plan to reform but then not
actually do it the pressure will be on
and technology plays a tremendous role
in keeping that pressure on them to
reform that's right but it the history
of this is there's always these very
beautiful revolutionary moments and some
of them go very well after that and some
of them don't what is genuinely novel
about this is it North Korea
so probably not going to be possible
anymore for anybody besides North Korea
the the idea of a country that is just
totally off the grid where people in
that country have no idea what's
happening in any other country is
probably a thing of the past but there's
a problem at the opposite extreme too if
you look at a country like East Timor
that came into all this oil wealth and
said we're going to handle it totally
transparently any citizen can check our
bank balances then the citizens start
saying hey I can see your bank balance
how come I don't have a job yet right
because when that information is
available people do want you to act on
it immediately and sometimes those
expectations are unrealistic the
fundamental points is about economics
like if you can get economics right as
Maslow's hierarchy of needs people want
to see opportunities they want jobs they
want food on their table they want their
kids to have a better life than they do
if you can deliver that you probably
won't have the volunteers that we've
seen in the Middle East Generation Y
that is leading these revolutions and
using technology really wants
accountability first and if there is
democracy that comes with that that's
obviously also a very good thing but we
do agree that the young generation is
going to be shaping the future of these
societies and most certainly their
economies which is why what's happening
with youth and technology is so
important for the future of economic
competition thanks very much for your
insights more on that and other relevant
topics at big thing calm